Oh,
madame Christie, dites bonjour à la caméra,
il se passe quelque chose, bébé, oui,
faites le jeu de frappe que vous m'avez montré,
rappelez-vous comment faites-vous, oh, j'aime vraiment
ce truc, il y avait quelque chose dans
la maison parce que je l'ai connecté.
comme
Carol, je dois juste filmer ce truc J'ai
installé mes caméras autour de la maison,
je peux peut-être capturer quelque chose ouais
hé micelle croustillante tu parles à
quelqu'un
c'est mon ami j'imagine que je regarde juste à
côté de toi quand il n'est rien
ce n'est pas simplement à propos  Christie,
c'est lié à votre côté de la famille,
il est certainement au courant de la fouille de
mon côté, nous sortons d'ici, prenez
la voiture et conduisez